now former U.S president Donald Trump
says he did nothing wrong after new
charges in the investigation into his
retention of classified documents
prosecutors accuse him of attempting to
destroy evidence they allege that he
asked a maintenance worker to delete
security camera video but Trump says
that he handed over the tapes to
investigators Trump has already pleaded
not guilty to 37 other charges in this
case well let's bring in Heidi jocastro
she joins us now with the latest from
Washington D.C Heidi perhaps
unsurprisingly more pushed back there
from Trump
that's that's right Nastasia this was on
a talk radio show earlier this morning
with the former president his voice was
heard it for the first time saying that
if he were to be convicted and sentenced
in any of these cases he's facing he
would not end his campaign to become
president again uh now this should come
as no surprise to anyone this is sort of
the red meat uh talk that Trump
supporters have always liked to hear
from their leader and a reality check
because with the timeline set forth at
this point it is still pretty unlikely
that any of these cases would complete a
trial or result uh in a conviction by
the time that the November elections
take place in 2024 still though this is
something that Trump is is likely to
repeat again when he continues his
campaign later today in Iowa Heidi tell
us a little more about these new charges
just how serious are they
these are very serious charges three of
them coming in this sensitive classified
documents case uh alleging that Trump
tried to hide or destroy evidence and
this is what the indictment laid out
that Trump after he was told that the
FBI wanted copies of the security
footage from his home in Mar-A-Lago that
he Trump then went to tell his employees
to find this footage and to delete it it
appears that ultimately this footage
wasn't deleted because indeed the FBI
did get its hands onto this and that's
some of the evidence that showed that
Trump's employees moved dozens and
dozens of boxes containing classified
information in an attempt to conceal
them from the FBI now the maintenance
worker that Trump gave these mandates to
he himself has also now been indicted in
this case for lying to federal agents
claiming that he had and then part of
this cover-up attempt that has been
alleged and now as far as Trump himself
this brings the total number of charges
in that case up to 40 that he has been
accused of and that's not even to
mention it's Anastasia you know the
other cases that he's facing any day now
we are expecting a possible indictment
in another case investigated by the
special Pro special counsel that is
looking at whether Trump tried to
overturn the 2020 election that could
come here in D.C also in Georgia a
related case is also likely to have have
indictments issued in very uh in very
little time so it's going to be a very
interesting election season in the U.S
Heidi jocaster there for us in
Washington DC thanks Heidi